the formal invasion of Gaza has begun
now the other day we saw tanks make
moves into Gaza which I think it's fair
to say an invasion but now we're seeing
fullscale boots on the ground there's
some wide wild rumors going around we
got to be very careful of but people are
sharing it Lebanese reporters claiming
there's even US troops there I want to
be careful about that because we just
don't know for sure we don't want to Fan
the Flames but this is getting uh it's
getting hot to say the least and uh
Saudi Arabia is warning the US things
could get uh uh pretty intense and they
can get pretty intense pretty quickly so
uh we're going to talk a lot about that
that's basically the the the dominating
story right now there's Mass protests
happening at Grand Central Station in
New York many Jewish individuals who
live in New York are protesting what's
going on and this could spiral out of
control very quickly